welcome to this video the final one for
tata steel 2013 the tournament in
vacanza which finished today and has
already reported yesterday it was won by
Road number one Magnus Carlsen they're
very convincing fashion we will look at
his final game also i'm going to start
with them let's say the the lesser less
exciting games and do this really
quickly i hope so at least I managed
I'll start with who you found against
Peter Leko both players can be I think
quite satisfied with the event we found
being a big underdog in this section she
made a pretty good impression winning
three games and um I needed to pull up
the table I think she's on minus two at
the end and this is really good we're
gaining a couple of points you always
need to consider that she absolutely had
no experience playing those super top
guys she never played on our door cards
and also before maybe once in rapid or
some some food some lesson prestigious
event where it wasn't so important but
John this is a big thing and Lego also
did did a good job by his song + 2 at
the end as well so good good result not
as well as well as the wrong word but
plus 2 is ohm that's good ok let's see
at the game GM the game we got them Lulu
peasant Lika was offering them the
marshal attack which she played place
for a couple of years now and huy phan
actually accepts the invitation and so
we've got the marshal and well nowadays
if white allows the marshal in a
top-class Avenger there are two types of
games so one type is why just wants to
draw
it's got plenty on this case she got
plenty of ways to do that and some false
line that leads to a draw or some end
game which can easily be drawn on the
other type is where white has some kind
of improvement cooked up trying to get
something and this game is clearly one
of the first and they get the first
cases we found basically just play dumb
a well-known theoretical line I don't
know it in detail don't play the marshal
but I know that all this has been played
and we see the clock times both players
have a plus time check that this was all
known Bishop f4 as a fun-looking
movement this has been introduced them
this last year or the year before I
think by aronian i'm not mistaken but
i'm not an expert aronian at least i
would be a good candidate yeah y term I
think cannot take but I don't want to
analyze this is all well known and white
can with Bishop takes d5 from go into
this position where black has obvious
compensation for the paul weitz king is
a bit weakened we've got opposite
colored bishops and a very strong Queen
on d5 and tier Queenie phone and like
prepares rook e8 wants to use the open
file of course and now just drop back
then this is the kind of position where
go fight some can them cannot do much
really like well get rook on the e-file
and in this way challenge the Queen now
and the problem is opposite colored
bishops we're in this for information it
is impossible for y to ever get past
porn on the queenside what's king is
with open and
the bishop on d5 is so much stronger
than this is bishop only one so it is a
complete complete draw this position and
then fact just a couple of Hoops later
the jaw was agreed yeah 7333 moves 37
moves I'm sorry and Valley some time
spent yeah this happens in those long
forced lines and this is the reason why
white I'm very often nowadays place some
earlier deviation to avoid the marshal
but of course it's very understandable
that we found after such a long
tournament she rather play em play
theoretical draw then then risked so
much it's really a long event downtown
what can you do and for from like what
what should make oh do play some other
line that he's not really familiar with
his playing the marshal for four years
so on what can you do it the draw ok on
the next game I'm going to look at is
some Nakamura against Hari Krishna and
nakamura playing g3 he's playing this
move from time to time when he wants to
get out of any theoretical discussion d3
and now a hurry Krishna played f5
occupying the center and now we have
yeah some sort of pills defense reverse
or modern reversed this Knight c3 set up
as some of course it's playable it's
also playable with colored roots colors
reversed um but one one issue is of this
night sometimes it's not so well placed
because black has got a pawn on c6 the
night is often better placed here if
there's a knight on c6 but this pawn
always limits this night a bit and dumb
therefore it often needs to be
repositioned later you form and like
just keeps it simple by exchanging I
think this is also probably
yeah we have a symmetrical porn
formation White has fianchetto and black
retreats this Bishop to f8 it's fairly
symmetrical one point is this formation
where I think that black is better off
with the porn here this offers on each
square for the Queen and it limits wide
sir Knight you know we've got a couple
of really normal-looking moves night h4
provoked you 60 black always black
needed to play jus 6 and not Sofia and
shadowed that's really not so much
happening in the next couple of moves
Queen f8 controls the age six square
it's not really that wide with
frightening bishop / to h6 but now aged
60 threatened by black so wyd needs to
do a side step again with the Queen
black cover tonight should be f1 b5 yeah
and here I'm not one hundred percent
sure because so it's really despite its
appearance it's not not so easy this
position um no la camara played a six
and I think probably you should just
take and yeah get this game over with
it's it's not a great position for white
anyway with this misplaced night amongst
others on c3 but what he's doing is he
plays a six and it's a question um if
this point is the weakness I mean okay a
seven can be weakness as well but this
is some very difficult to attack and
this pawn on a six can can be a problem
we see a couple of moves later and now a
bit was a bit of a mysterious move
oopsie eight white played king edge too
and now black returned I really didn't
understand the point of those moves but
okay probably i need to I'm
spend a lot of time to explain or find
some explanation it's just look what
what's happening that's an interesting
point pretty soon 93 yeah what did
regrouping the night on h4 was really
bad so with this route turned its back
into play the problem is white has got
pieces here and black Scott ponds that
are ready to advance and white has no
play at all and this is all a long-term
consequence of this somewhat misplaced
knight on c3 97 and now white played
before and yeah this is some this is an
interesting roof it fixes some the c5
square so wyd can probably try something
like this make use of the square but now
this pawn really am is it probably also
could have played Bishop to e3 covering
this square so that would be six is not
possible but then black plays c5 and as
mentioned he's got those ideas and black
is certainly a bit more comfortable so
he played this and after rugby 6 this
pawn is gone of course he didn't simply
overlook this um wyd get some
compensation and this is due to the fact
that he's got the c5 square and of
course this is a bit misplaced got an
exchange queen III attacking the pawn on
a 7 yeah this is a counter-attack so
white cannot really take them and now he
played f4 which is really a bit
weakening but I understand that what
wants to get some play going um maybe in
this position on black should have
played differently he played f6 very
solid move Adam I like him
set up f6 on I would prefer to take but
it's not easy take take take him and
then probably this simply the difference
is that on a five after trading on air
flow of course you are gave white the
center but it's a lot of mobile center
and you don't have a weakness on e5 in
the game just to compare the c5 pawn was
more of a weakness than the e4 pawn you
most need to compare those pawns and
like cannot really do much on you for
while white can do something against if
might we'll see what I'm talking about
see this regrouping the night is coming
to 2d three and then attacking the pawn
and this is an additional weakness while
black has no quick way to attack this
spawn he's always got his bed Bishop to
defend it young bed bishop bed bishops
protect good pawns a funny rule but at
sometimes really really working so i
have a look at this position white is a
pawn down but he's got counter play
against this pawn against this pawn and
it's just much more active the Snider's
is bad and honestly i don't think that
like has serious challenges chances to
win this position at least in the game I
don't really think that that there was
much room for improvement I mean I
didn't analyze that it's so deeply but
it's it seems difficult to to make any
substantial progress we can look at look
at the rest just a second
okay so age for King g7 and both sides
are just trying to improve their pieces
a bit but down it's a push-up h3 is of
course funny if black would take then
check that's this this move on 96 that's
90 f to end this piece is trapped quite
funny so we've got this exchange and now
wyd get the night on c5 at least after
this Bishop is exchanged they're simply
simply nothing I'm much happening this
is the extra pawn on a six and it's
completely worthless they continued for
a while but I think like has zero
chances to win I'd even rather play wide
actually that the danger of this kind of
positions as white has a clear
positional compensation with the active
rook and the activity and sometimes if
you're not careful is like you lose one
porn and the activity persists and then
white has a pH saw all of a sudden so um
yeah I'm like actually we turned the
pawn and now gets to play c5 this was
the idea he returned one porn but got
rid of the the visit the passive
formation that he had now also checking
this pawn so you are making sure that
actually enough is exchanged to secure
draw check began up like is gone down
but he calculated this is 220 clear draw
getting the last form so on maybe how
accretion I had some some chances around
to move 22 and move 30 here here around
this point I like as mentioned instead
of f6 the capture more but I after this
is also not so easy it's not clear
captain super clear extra porn
but black hand can try okay um next game
is allow me against zooskool off to tail
enders looking for win Lamia had a big
chance against an aunt but didn't didn't
take it and look cool off simply has a
complete horror show of a tournament
let's see what happens in this game
Queens gambit declined and Sokoloff
played c5 the so-called improved terror
Sean see me tarish seat XD 5 and now the
overwhelming main line is night XD five
but this move is actually quite quite
interesting it's not often no plates are
often but it's not bad white captures
with the Queen this is the most
promising jobs and this is just just
equal probably not much happening and
here I'm black has two choices you can
play a very solid move 1965 and after a
form on take on c3 this kind of setup
this is a very solid for black or you
can play what Sokolov played it takes d5
which is also am rather solid but can
lead to shower play right now played a
form which is probably the most testing
if why it would play some slow moves
from let's say g3 or just for argument's
sake then this is a big temple and this
kind of stuff what needs to be careful
cannot play some some routine moves III
what we still ok of course it's not
great for white but of course playable
and before more principle though 96 and
we should be fine this is the idea of
the sea formless and now black just
captured he can also take on e4 with the
night which
it's even the the more popular option
and very often check can lead to this
kind of endgame wear black has good
chance is to equalize okay um takes only
for anderson also as an end game which
looks check around equal i would say
black has um a very untidy bone
structure of course but he's got an
extra porn and bad porn structure often
means open lines open files and like
gets decent activity here with the
channel and down yeah now count play
against c3 so this was covered and now
we see the one open file in action
against the f porn route to age four and
now black plate III which is a good move
returning one porn and making sure that
the e-file stays closed so that e-cigs
some doesn't become a weakness check
check and takes only three now like a
scott dimension def far and well
positioned right i think this is around
equal and in fact after a couple of
moves we got more exchanges and here
arguably black is even somewhat easier
to play this bishops having a bit of a
pressure on c3 while this Bishop is
doing doing nothing cannot attack a
single porn at the moment okay can you
take let's say g7 after we should be
five but this look f2 and if we should
be five at some other point there's
always two six while white cannot move
away there's a spawn but all in all it
sir it's very equal I'll fast forward
perform for a while until we get a
critical position this is deep in the
end game Black has one upon even
but he doesn't have much chance is to
convert as the Jeep or this week check
check yeah a TM we see that like a
managed to get on the second-ranked end
is so therefore the more active and of
course he didn't want to lose the poor
to get the king active but still it's um
it's very dry yeah white uses jeep on
for some counter play and then well you
could could always suggest some check
alternative moves um there's not really
a mistake check made yet but with
there's one one single moment where on
something hit something substantial
happen and this is exactly now here um
Lamia the white player play the rook f6
and in fact this move is losing
instantly if so cool off now would we
use his golden opportunity what he
should do is rook 86 the problem is you
need to have a check against the king
move if he moves now I've gotta check
and this concretely runs into this move
and what is why it's supposed to do now
it's quite funny that this is winning
what its sides it's just tactics if it's
just it's just possible to to analyze
this by my method of elimination if
white would would move the rock from the
F IRA let's say here then there's simply
King f1 king moves e 2 and the pawn
promotes
cut also this so you basically gain a
temple by playing the king with check
and this is the big point of the g2 this
is why the rook cannot leave the F file
so you cannot play rook move yeah you
can play something like this but this
also leads to win as black would play e
2 and then shield the King prevent
pairing King f1 at the end so white
cannot play a rook muth and if he plays
a king move let's say here then there's
King d3 and simply the sea poorness is
falling and this is so than a winning
end game with the two extra points so
this was a golden opportunity but it's
really a technical one maybe em if you
sometimes it's it's just a matter of
from matter of lucky I'm that you need
to an innocent in in the single position
where you have this kind of unexpected
chance that you really take a bit of a
time and and look at look at moves um
also could have really spent time you
spent three minutes yeah well if you're
in a bed tournament it wasn't difficult
really group g2 I mean what candy that
moves do we have you only have the King
muth cannot move the pawn and you can
move the rock along the G file or h1a
drew cage one is completely useless and
I don't know rook g3 yeah well no idea
what he what he miscalculated them he
played the king he won and now it's a
little opportunity is over
King f3 if now you would play not just
for example you will play this then
white can go back on the F file so like
this this doesn't really give you any em
any progress how should black continue
now if you play e2 with this idea you
just stay and here you can actually
promote yourself like g7 this even
losses probably okay so in the game oops
in the game they will skin your free
plate check and they continued project
and even at gentle got this chat got
this is a queen endgame check your chat
i'm doing this very quickly but i can
assure you there was nothing happening
check check like even one upon here
check but the King position is to open
chant will always be a perpetual until
mid Quincy to the Queen exchange was
shank initiated to get King were the
skin so I think both players are glad
that this tournament is over they both
didn't win a game and and lost lost
quite a couple especially sokoloff
really is it's a much better player than
here then he seems to be if you look at
just this tournament all right um so
what came next time let's go with kawana
against Aronian we have berlin again ok
and Kara wanna allows the Berlin Wall
and game check
but didn't really am come up with
something great I mean also i'm not a
big theoretical expert the only thing
they know is that he rather quickly am
what's worse so on let's look at this
position the sun after after 18 moves
and i think he can also already conclude
that black has no problems at all he's
got the king safely evacuated from the
middle of the board can probably step up
him he's got a good bishop which is
secured on five attacking this weakness
and what does white half yeah not much
really played rookie to covering this
and now black regrouped the night 36 and
like it's already much more comfortable
now g5 and now this is an interesting
moment here aronian played Bishop takes
g5 and this is smart this is maybe a
surprise if you don't know this this
line too well it's always almost always
good for black to get rid of the dark
squared bishop in these structures as
the dark squared bishop is limited by by
this pond or general speaking by these
pawns also it's sometimes good to
liquidate a night as Knights can combat
fight for the light squares and this
bishop cannot so this exchange in a way
increases this blockade concrete in in a
concrete way like our already I also has
got the default and can play a form
using his phone against three so the
black majority is the more dangerous
here already it's hard to see how wide
should be able to to move from his pawns
so I'm pretty yeah pretty bad
set up that Kara wanna go see em and
he's he's a real trouble a form and yeah
black just grabbed a spawn and one one
reason why you could do that is after a
four black can simply sacrificed the
exchange and aronian gladly gladly did
this because he gained a second porn on
c2 and also now with four against two we
see that this will be really dangerous
passed pawns white captured and rook
takes our now Lex got a very dangerous
upon and of course got great pieces
while whites night is especially a bad
on edge for this is why I'm black tries
to exchange it okay like that position
is probably simply simply winning it's
it's not complete easy win but um it
should be it should be a decisive it see
Paul Yeji four tries to get some counter
play of course why there's already a bit
desperate here on the idea of black guy
would take on g4 like takes on g4 then
then you get see fall back John this is
not the best of course you want to keep
this strong pawn so we just played the
night to to be three yeah rook takes he
couldn't take really on on b3 and here
I'm it's um it's a question um black
hair Scott and this is I think one
problem of this position it's clear that
black has and always decisive advantage
but you've got so many good moves that
you can easily lose the threat choosing
one of the the good moves um he captured
on d 2 which probably keeps the
advantage but maybe 94
backwards was even even better so so so
in this position improve about on 93 and
maybe play move like g6 just freezing
the King side so that f5 is not possible
and then play be 5c 5 and so on just can
continue with the slow advance of the
pawns it seems so it seems over really
but this this is also still keeping a
really big advantage so it's not a big
mistake so is the simpler approach well
when black still has the strong strong
porn and this rook is somewhat boxed in
so a couple of moves later we see that
black still as is much much better roop
c1 and here it's not quite sure i'm not
quite sure what Aronian now now played
on it hit look to h5 which seems at
least unnecessarily complex I don't
really see why not before just pushing
the the pawn if the right now tries to
grab the porn let's just put it on the
board then the B porn just promotes no
way to stop it you can even know after
you hear you can you can exchange books
and so no big deal the corn is simply
promoting it's not not quite sure what
he did rogue age 5 check and now white
gain to spawn it's a probably still
winning but some giving away a bit of
ground um one thing is look at the
clocks Aronian has got huge time left he
tends to win this winning positions play
a bit too quickly it's an autumn
that is very often often making check
them I think he's bought quite a bit of
bit of advantage already and a couple of
moves later check um here he could play
c3 but he went went back to to h6
covering the sixth-ranked and it's it's
still it's still a better for blankets
no no question but white has got the f
porn and just a couple of moves later in
fact if you believe the computer
assessment that's really a didn't have
the time to look myself I usually do a
computer check but look a bit of myself
um it goes quite quickly white um gets
the f porn going and manages to escape
just by by a threat but he manages to
escape into check look at the airport
check-in term covering a v1 check yeah
this was the mentioned escape like now
has got night egghead sorry look at
Bishop against against the rook which is
of course a theoretical draw you can try
on and tend to play this and hope that
the the rook the player with the single
rook is not able to defend it with a
little time but this is a big advantage
of the the increment time control the
Fisher time controls where you get 30
seconds and move so that you actually
have the chance to defend this and Cara
wanna only camp defended this I think
flawlessly yeah it doesn't make much
sense to do an analysis of this if
really a ton of comments request for an
analysis of this end game I will do this
and show how this drunk click done check
there are various way to do this we
check they practiced all this for more
than 100 moves total check and you see
that Kara wanna always has got like two
or three minutes so he's got a bit of
time to to organize so think about his
defense check and draw greet after 104
moose yes certainly disappointed for
aronian who completely outplayed Kara
wanna and I only needed to to hear to
actually win the game at the end but
didn't didn't manage probably by playing
a just a bit too quickly okay so next
game let's have a look at the tournament
winner cards and playing with black
against arnesh geary cards now had the
chance if he would win the game to to
break another record of garry kasparov
soo won this tournament in YK 1999 with
the really brilliant score of 10 out of
13 and Carlton had nine and a half
before this round so a draw would even
this so and when he would repeat
Kasparov Cisco and with the winner would
even um improve upon this so we got down
mg6 our Kings Indian arun felt and give
a place gives us fashionable every move
and cards and nurture allows the
transposition into the Kings in the end
with somewhat unusual move order with
this early five um I'm not sure what the
point of the early if I for any to me to
be honest Bishop g7 would be normal I'm
giving our plate d5 which isn't a
mistake but I think the question for me
is why not 90 to the point of 92 would
be the following Bishop g7 93 m so
just keep the center and now I'm the
question is what black should play now
the issue is that castles after Bishop
g5 is a well-known line which is better
for white and very difficult would like
to get a decent position from this so
when cards and probably had some
concrete idea after after 92 e to yeah
maybe capturing I'm not sure or
something entirely different no idea ok
but give you a plate t5 which isn't the
bad news that just transpose it to
something else but should be three this
this threat of course needs to be
attended to and after couple of moves we
have transposed to an old out main line
of the sameish Kings in yet in fact this
line with a five was a favorite of
kasparov some different moves honor of
course not with three f3 and the early
five but this was something that
kasparov has played more than once the
normal rules for black na 197 or e6 this
is some of the most played news is 697
and Calvin is playing a very old
fashioned move now which is basically
never played nowadays as it is believed
to give white a pretty distinct
advantage so quite a surprising choice
we should f2 we worship to have sixes
the idea is to get rid of the bad bishop
but white has Queenie one which is the
key move and this prevents this Bishop
age 49 to d7 King b1 normal move Bishop
e7 ok this protects the deep on and
prepares the the next move the blackest
i'm going to play c3 and now we played
them and play them the move c5 which is
in a way the reason for the upcoming
troubles that like is going to be in but
the problem was that you really don't
know what what you should play instead
of this move
White has a very pleasant position he
can play Bishop to h3 this is one issue
activating this this Bishop and also at
the right moment after this Bishop move
and maybe after the exchange white can
often just play G for an H for making
sure that the King side is closed and
then play on the queenside later after
due preparation so c5 is really a moved
to to stop the queenside expansion early
and now give you played very
straightforward manner but I think in a
good way he took on on on c6 and now
played c5 this was the idea opening up
the position immediately getting the D
file so the rook is well positioned and
black of course needs to dig with the
pawn we can can put this on the board
and we see that white has now opened his
position the position nicely for the
bishops this is a bad piece on age 5 and
this these pawns are what's a week so um
Carson certainly didn't on yeah improve
the reputation of this line which is
really a bad one and like now really is
in trouble that's can continue for a
couple of moves this is of course nice
activating the bishop and maybe
intending and now a Bishop to e6 at some
point yeah like it sound really having
in an ugly position it's full of
weaknesses and you don't really have any
any concrete play 2 to get to attack
something or or get something against
the King whatever it's it's really a
simply simply bad for black exchanged a
couple of pieces and now with 97 intends
to improve some pieces we should
60 96 yeah sacrificing the sea the sea
porn this was a very weak porn anyway
and the russian alison rather give up
the porn and try for how to play with
maybe if you got the chance queen here
on da porn so it's clear that Dwight has
some pretty distinct advantage going to
see five don't um here it's very
difficult um you replayed the move
Bishop g2 which is really a bit
mysterious it's probably just covering
f3 to allow 192 there free porn would
would hang if you don't don't play this
preparation move Bishop f1 numb by the
way was also i'm a good move maybe a
better move it's very difficult the
ideas if Blackwood now try to double up
on under the before then you've got
Bishop a six-letter as an answer but you
played this route to be seven and the
question is if white maybe can improve
around here it's not easy at all I mean
the computer assessing this as fled out
winning for white but I don't know for
human I think it's it's not so easy but
probably should be much better but it's
not not easy to play he played King a
one and this allows distinct counter
play but cam
not quite sure what what you should play
maybe night night to night to e to the
black still has a 5 coming rights not
it's not completely easy now black has
some play let's say king then a four
before no in it so it's not a very
secure a king position and then like an
can take on before yeah this is not
really an improvement he played King to
a one and now I'm 97 was a mistake yeah
but if I've was an interesting move
leading two to two very good counter
play for black the ideas of Whitewood
would take now there's Luca eight and
now like Sir plays sighs even
overwhelming maybe this Bishop everyone
was really stronger than Bishop g2 the
bishop on f1 can be a handy defense of
peace yeah if I fun gifts gives real
counter play around here here probably
something else maybe maybe still 92 it's
a it's difficult okay plate King a one
and now color should play a five with
the counter play he played this move
though and this could lead into a good
lead to some trouble this was played but
Queen a to Queen a three was was much
better for me covering the son of this
pawn and intending to further protected
with rook
Group C 3 the thing is that Bishop takes
c3 is not working it's now black is in a
pin and this means he needs to lose time
to continue and so this is probably
really winning four wide cannot take on
b3 yeah what you played giving clearly
six on is some unfortunately allowing an
instant draw and here Carlton could have
played Bishop takes p3 and we've got
basically the same as in the game so on
he played this and again here Queen 83
was the the more testing move probably
22 to White's advantage played this and
now contemplate Bishop takes b3 and
force the draw and we see my sister draw
white needs to exchange screens now and
the fee he takes now at he must take
cannot cannot read Ian avoid this then
this is a drum what needs to look at
this threat and the only way to to
secure this is roxy to check and again
here you've got the check my thread yeah
whites pieces are not helping him came
back it's a perpetual so on at the end
draw an escape for cars and I think
these Queen a three things were really
worrying but he had some counter play I
mean you cannot simply just always look
at the computer leave out the computer
just says white is winning all the way
here but it's not so easy black Scott
now some really active pieces the rooks
get a 505 a 4 and it's just a pawn while
whites pieces are not doing so much on
the King side so it wasn't like giving
was missing a super
the window or anything but Carlton
certainly wasn't slide trouble Queen III
could have been a really tricky okay so
the next game is where is kayaking
against fan vini and surprisingly
haven't really played the dragon again
he lost against lakewood before in this
tournament and kayaking simply repeats
the the line that lego plate and to be
honest I don't really see why as black
you would go for this line it seems
completely unattractive to me but okay
it's a chess is also a matter of taste
sometimes but I don't really know why
what black should should go for this
yeah it seems to me that you're just a
little bit worse for ever against this
night on c5 and is somewhat better white
piece placement ok so this position now
find really played the move h5 and I
think this is some helping white a lot
in developing is play maybe you should
play some some some slow moves instead
when I'm what I'm getting at is that
right now can play g4 and I don't really
see why you should play age 52 to make
this move yeah even worse you could have
played instead of h5 some other moves
for example Knight to f4 Queen here and
then you should be six of course um it's
it's not great for black but I mean this
position is not great maybe I'm some too
biased but I really don't like blacks
position got a worse pawn structure
worst pieces why would you play this I
mean the computer still says it's about
equal and like has got some certainly
some defensive
horses he's not lost or something but
it's still an unattractive position at
least to me yeah well h5 didn't help g4
certainly something that white likes to
play yeah if I've gaining a tempo and
right now played Quincy one maybe he
didn't really appreciate this move I'm
not sure what clears that black is now
in some trouble okay he's got this trick
Dwight defend it against this and now
Queen g3 this intense to maneuver
towards the king or maybe this oops
night efore to f6 or to g5 you now
played a five and after this is already
in huge trouble probably am it's not
even in position you can defend after a
five the computer suggests a very cool
defense which however for human as
simply are not possible to find maybe or
very difficult the computer wants to
play rugby 8 and this is really a clever
move the ideas of white now place the
same as in the game then like and play
the interesting move rook takes be three
takes and naji to forking oops walking
both are epcm and regaining regaining
the cool point is even adjuster to show
black can't even take here and after
captures Queen 85 is a very nice double
attack and here black is even winning
but ok white had various ways to to play
it differently you don't need to play
Queen age for in something ok he played
however a five and we see the difference
rather rather quickly Queen age four and
now black played this move but if
light wood plane ig2 now why should God
Bishop takes f7 and this is why by rugby
age and rook takes me three was
essential to get rid of this this night
in the game instead of ninety two words
it's basically the same he played a four
though which considering the answer
looks really a bit weird Jack Wighton
just took it of course and just as after
not g2 and black has no move of course
Queen takes it's just general pain and
King takes change seven picks up the
loose Queen on c7 so involve really a
weird move played King g7 and now just
94 and intending this and yeah then
really doesn't have a move and resigned
so he lost two dragons at the end of the
tournament and he really has suffered
with black losing all those Sicilians he
made a really good score with white
winning a couple of games but he really
got thrashed in the Sicilian yeah I
listened a bit to them to the life
comments today on on the ICC where they
mentioned yeah that this it's hard
nowadays if you don't play you 45 at the
top level double king porn as it is so
solid it's very helpful to to have a
solid option available and when really
simply doesn't have this he always plays
this very direct and sharp stuff and
loses quite frequently against the top
guys instead of let's say place i'm
boring berlin wall now now now and then
and then tend to draw some games okay so
big quick nobly big win quick win for
kayaking at the end so we've got only
one game left and this is one how
against anand won how having a not a
great tournament but
this game he played really well against
the world champion we've got a scotch
four nights and not the most aggressive
line ever now this is the complete main
line and here for more than 100 years
Bishop g5 has been the main line um and
Riza recently this move h3 which doesn't
look too terrifying admittedly in
connection with this has been introduced
them or maybe let's say unearthed
certainly has been played before back
from neck last yeah who stated that it's
probably not leading to some some big
edge for white but it's certainly an
easy to play position yeah this is
certainly true white has some has an
easy to play position on this general
dis opening the Scotch phone ads can be
recommended to players who like open
positions with peace play with with
without taking too much risks because
it's very hard for black to get
something substantial here I think I
don't play dumb play ed played normal a
normal defensive move Bishop t6 dokie 1
and Bishop f4 this is one idea of the
set up getting the bishops exchanged
some tongue and this looks fairly normal
and um I play this this opening is black
and this is exactly how I would have
played so I'm only here I would have
played differently def definitely here
here are not played rook to e8 which is
probably all right but I mean he's the
world champion who am I to criticize
this I can only say that what I would
have done is to play we should be seven
because I'd really don't like the idea
that white would take my bishop here I
think we should be seven I would play
Bishop d7 Luke f2e 8 and ruined King f8
trying to get rid of the rooks and
centralized the King because I think in
a pure minor piece end game it's
difficult for y2 to get anything and in
the game he allowed this exchange and
this and this I know it looks a bit
uncomfortable I also thought just my
opinion and it's a purely strategical
thing that rook takes c6 would be better
here but it took with the pawn and also
I just recognized the clock times and
was playing very quickly maybe I don't
know maybe he was thinking that among
how was just playing very solidly going
for quick draw something and then he saw
that he was maybe in slide trouble the
thing is I believe that black has some
slight problems in this position it's
simply that it's it's the position is
wide open and it's not entirely
symmetrical so the bishop here is just
better than the night legs got three
Pawn islands against two so there are
little things but they add up and white
is some is certainly easier to play a
couple of moves later here we see that
white now has play on the C file black
is still very solid I mean he should
promi with perfect play draws is somehow
but it's not easy look two against one
this is a potential passport and this is
simply a great piece yeah but it cannot
jump to be six it's working along those
two diagonals Knight to d7 and just a
couple of moves later we see why it is
slightly better and it's very
uncomfortable for black i thinkI they
kept playing very quickly i'm surprised
yeah maybe I'm just I'm just influenced
by the result of the scam you probably
guessed by now if you don't know that
one how won this game and but i think
really black should should invest some
time to try to defend
he played the whole everything instantly
you form yeah now and now let's say I'm
very curious how much time on unspent he
instantly took with the pawn it's very
interesting I thought that night takes
before here was a very serious
alternative and much better actually hmm
I thought this would be an improvement
when he played this so quickly um the
ideas of course if white would take the
simple solution so to say that black
takes with the porn and he's got
counterplay he'd like to get into a rook
endgame from because the winning of the
drawing chances there would be what
would be better it certainly as
profitable would like to get the night
exchange for the bishop um the the
problem may be the problem why didn't
play it but I don't know he played all
this instantly I'm not sure how much
thought he put into this at all if white
would play king g one black has the
interesting defensive move rook to d6
which at first looks a bit strange
because of this word blackened check
Black has this way of defending there's
always a checkup then this check at the
check and black wins even so night takes
check king he erupted e6 and this is why
white probably needs to retreat and now
some let's say King f6 maybe even trying
to activate the King more I think this
looks like a better defense but ok it
took action now the bishop is strong on
c4 and the King here I mean this looks
from week very uncomfortable from like
what he he continued to play instant
moves really weird King age 7 and say I
Roxy five just protecting against 95
don't want to exchange him
get the pawn some are just rolling
forward and where's your counter play
yeah play seven this week yeah by now
what is what is just completely winning
and not sure if there was after after
this transformation of the pawn
structure if there really was a defense
it looks very difficult these pawns just
advanced and what is black going to do
about it yeah and a7 is gone and with it
the game and now now analysts taking
huge time after a six really interesting
yeah probably i'm just understanding too
too little about chess I really thought
he should have looked much earlier
because at least for me this position
looked very very dangerous for like 50
moves already but I'm probably i'm
probably missing something if he plays
this so quickly and only now now he
spend your time but now it's already too
late have no way to defend and he's
associating some sort of song last hope
counter play with the king even gap at
the a pond and chow just kind of a spy
check on f3 and rook seven the point is
like were threatening Luke h2 + f2 and
now after Luke h2 that's just look
Chancellor three and white wins so the
win 4-1 how sort of compensating for
some some
losses in this tournament beating the
world champion and I think maybe I not
really I was in he was in in blitz mode
until this point way really was in
trouble at least my point of view the
computer is just giving wide let's say
half a pawn advantage but I think it's
much worse so yeah bit of a negative way
to conclude this tournament for the
world champion who really played plenty
good tournament with the good+ score
which shone at into other in other years
easily could have been enough to fight
for a first place and without this loss
of course this loss really said in
backward um he had a good tournament
before that also winning this very
really great game against ronnian on
round four if you haven't seen this
already it's really the candidate for
game of the year already after four
weeks in this new year yeah thanks for
watching this final video on this
tournament and um I'll be back soon with
some other content of course this has
been more than two weeks of serious
world-class chess and i'll be doing an
upcoming week some some other content
but maybe i'm taking two or three days
off because it was really quite
something to invest three hours each
evening to do those videos and because
it's the preparation time and i need to
upload and and so on it always it almost
always took two to three hours so yeah
thanks for watching and I'll be back
soon and a couple of days probably